I think we have to begin the long term
process of reconstructing the
institutions that that that were built
you know roughly 60 years ago and I
think in certain circumstances we need
to build whole new institutions that is
a very difficult business and it will
involve lots of frustration um
historically if you look at the United
States America has always shown some
wariness of being being fixed into
international institutions we have been
jealous of our sovereignty jealous of
our ability to act independently ah and
in today's world where America is
relative power these are the other
nations is not as great as it was when
the institutions of the post post-war
period were built the compacts that we
will strike will in some ways be more
difficult compacts than the compact the
Franklin Roosevelt and Harry Truman
struck that there will not be an
expectation instead of that we can be as
dominant in those institutions as we
were particularly at the beginning at
the at the at the UN the IMF World Bank
NATO etc but we must strike them
nonetheless America's best leaders have
had the ability to convince Americans
that in an interdependent world in which
we were on which our fate dependent on
what other nations did and so we could
not isolate ourselves but in which we
did not have the power or indeed the
legitimacy to act in an imperial way
doing whatever we wanted around the
world forcing other nations to bend to
our will because there are limits to our
power that that that in fact we had no
choice but to try to build the
mechanisms for cooperation so even
though it's a frustrating and difficult
business I think it's in urgent business
when one looks about trying to find the
legitimate way to deal with jihadist
terrorism to deal with climate change to
deal with threats from global public
health deal with the potential for the
kind of dangerous financial instability
that we saw in the East Asian financial
crisis in the late 1990s so I do think
it is going to be it is central to omit
will be it should be central to American
foreign policy in the coming generator
you